- It's an amazing thing
to be a part of something
so magical, like such a big,
huge thing of pop culture.
Like, did that set in
right away for y'all,
or did it take a few seasons?
- No, no, it did not set.
I mean, we weren't sure if it
was even gonna work as a show.
'Cause there had not been
any real series on cable
that were hits at the time.
And when it came out, though,
it got these crazy reviews
all over the place.
And then it started to get a following,
and there were billboards
and that kind of thing,
and it just kept going from there.
And now it seems like it's
more popular than it ever was.
- And that's amazing to be a
part of something that huge.
- I think 50 years from now,
they'll still be watching this thing.
- I know well, it's a
classic, sign of a classic.
Well, the show famously ended
in the middle of a scene and a song.
No one knows if Tony
Soprano lived or died,
so what do you think?
- I think Tony Soprano is alive and well.
And eating onion rings in New Jersey.
That's what I think.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Okay, that sounds awesome.
- That's what I think.
- Okay, I have a feeling
you have a different opinion.
(Kelly laughing)
- Of course he always
got a different opinion.
- I saw him.
He did the thinking man pose.
- I think the cut to black
was his point of view,
and that's the end for the character.
That was the last thing he saw
and then it was (indistinct).
- And Michael is wrong, Kelly.
(audience laughing)
Listen to uncle Steve, Michael is wrong.